recordemos cuando es que decimos que
algo es un gas ideal cuales son las
suposiciones clave que definen a un gas
idea bueno la primera suposición es que
no existen interacciones inter
moleculares no hay
interacciones inter moleculares
y eso qué significa bueno un ejemplo de
interacciones inter moleculares son los
puentes de hidrógeno supongamos que
tenemos dos moléculas de agua que se
encuentran cerca tenemos un oxígeno con
dos hidrógenos y otro oxígeno con dos
hidrógenos
y esto se encuentra en estado gaseoso
estamos hablando de vapor de agua y como
sabemos en una molécula de agua el
oxígeno tiene una carga parcial negativa
y el hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva así que se atraen entre ellos
bueno pues estos son los famosos puentes
de hidrógeno y esa es una interacción
inter molecular pero también podemos
pensar en las fuerzas dipolo dipolo que
dependen de la polaridad de las
moléculas o también podemos pensar en
las fuerzas de van der vaart que son
interacciones inter moleculares en las
que existe una polaridad aleatoria y
puede existir ya sea una atracción o una
pulsión hacia el otro extremo de una
molécula cercana entonces para los gases
ideales y para la aplicación de la ley
de los gases ideales vamos a suponer que
no hay interacciones inter moleculares y
si las hay para poder suponer que el gas
se comporta como un gas ideal podemos
suponer que esto es despreciable o
simplemente que no sucede ahora la
segunda clave es suponer que el volumen
de las moléculas del gas es despreciable
respecto al volumen del contenedor
entonces el volumen el volumen de las
moléculas
delicadas
despreciable
pero miren en realidad no hay gases que
sean absolutamente ideales obviamente
las moléculas de todos los gases ocupan
un volumen y existe algún tipo de
interacción inter molecular como las
fuerzas de bander valls y todo eso pero
resulta que bajo la mayoría de las
condiciones en las que trabajamos con
muchos gases estas son suposiciones
razonables o al menos para muchas
condiciones estas suposiciones son
razonables y en particular estas dos
posiciones son razonables para gases
reales suposiciones razonables
para casos reales
reales a temperaturas relativamente
altas
y presiones relativamente bajas
bajas y obviamente eso depende del gas
del que estemos hablando para saber qué
tan alta necesitamos que sea la
temperatura o qué tan baja necesitamos
que sea la presión y otra forma de
pensar en esto es que bueno los gases
son cada vez menos ideales conforme nos
acercamos al punto de condensación
entonces si empezamos con una
temperatura muy baja o una presión alta
es muy probable que el gas pase a estado
líquido y conforme nos acercamos al
punto de condensación el gas se
comportará menos y menos idea pero como
hemos visto en muchos vídeos si podemos
hacer estas suposiciones entonces
podemos aplicar la ley del gas ideal que
dice que la presión por el volumen del
gas ideal es igual al número de moles
por la constante universal de los gases
la temperatura medida en que el bien
ahora vamos a pensar en por qué esto es
razonable para la mayoría de los gases a
temperaturas relativamente altas y
presiones bajas y después pensemos en
cuándo es que esto deja de ser cierto
conforme nos acercamos al punto de
condensación en el que la temperatura es
baja o la presión es mucho más alta
vamos a ver analicemos esos tres casos
en el primero lo pondré de otro color
en el primero tenemos una temperatura
alta y una presión baja después vamos a
analizar el caso en el que tenemos una
temperatura baja
temperatura baja y después vamos a
analizar el caso en el que tenemos una
presión alta
ok entonces por qué es razonable que los
gases ideales se comporten de esta forma
a temperaturas relativamente altas y
presiones relativamente bajas bueno voy
a dibujar un contenedor estas son las
paredes del contenedor imaginen que está
en tres dimensiones pero yo sólo lo
dibujaré en dos dimensiones y ahora
vamos a dibujar las moléculas de gas ok
entonces a temperaturas altas las
moléculas se mueven muy rápido pero
recuerden que para este caso nos
encontramos a una presión baja así que
no rebotan mucho con las paredes del
contenedor ahora este es un gas real sus
moléculas claramente ocupan un volumen y
vamos a suponer que en el mundo real
existen algunas interacciones inter
moleculares con moléculas cercanas pero
como se encuentra a altas temperaturas
las moléculas se mueven muy rápido así
que en realidad no hay una interacción
tan grande
fuerzas de atracción que podemos obtener
como por ejemplo los puentes de
hidrógeno o de otro tipo en realidad no
se toman en cuenta e igualmente como nos
encontramos a una presión baja no
existen tantas colisiones así que
podemos suponer que el volumen que ocupa
el gas es despreciable en relación al
volumen del contenedor al menos en mi
mente me imagino que el contenedor es
enorme a comparación de las moléculas de
gas entonces cuando pensamos en cómo
podrían interactuar está bien que no
tomemos en cuenta las interacciones que
existen entre las moléculas ya sea tanto
por las colisiones como por alguna
repulsión electrostática incluso podemos
suponer que se encontrarán tan lejos
unas de las otras la mayor parte del
tiempo que una especie de fuerza de
atracción como por ejemplo los puentes
de hidrógeno o las interacciones dipolo
dipolo en realidad son despreciables así
que esta es la razón por la que en estas
condiciones suena lógico que la mayor
de los gases reales se comporten como
gases ideales o bueno al menos eso
suponemos para aplicar la ley de los
gases ideales ok ahora veamos los otros
dos casos supongamos que tenemos una
temperatura baja vamos a ver en una
situación en la que tenemos una
temperatura baja voy a dibujar el mismo
contenedor
aquí tenemos el mismo contenedor y ahora
sí tenemos una temperatura baja cuando
tenemos un gas ideal la temperatura no
importa mucho pero ahora que tenemos una
temperatura baja las moléculas cercanas
especialmente las que tienen fuerzas de
atracción tendrán la oportunidad de
interactuar porque las moléculas no se
están moviendo tan rápido entonces si
las fuerzas de atracción empiezan a
tomar importancia ustedes creen que
mantener el volumen y la temperatura
constante a una temperatura baja a bueno
y el número de moléculas constante todos
ellos constantes ustedes creen que a un
gas real a una temperatura baja tendrá
una presión más baja o más alta que un
gas ideal los invito a que pause en el
vídeo y lo analicen un poco
bueno como nos encontramos a una
temperatura baja estamos suponiendo que
mantenemos de la temperatura el volumen
y el número de moles para gases ideales
y reales
y reales constantes y si comparamos la
presión de un gas real con la presión de
un gas ideal que creen que pase bueno en
un gas real las moléculas están
moviéndose y pasan unas junto a otras
por lo que tendrán más tiempo para
atraerse con los puentes de hidrógeno y
las fuerzas de van der vaart así que
podrían pasar más tiempo chocando entre
ellas o agrupándose que chocando contra
las paredes entonces imaginen que si
mantenemos esta temperatura baja
constante en las dos situaciones
diferentes es decir la de gases reales y
la de gases ideales si también
mantenemos el volumen constante y el
número de moles también es constante
podemos imaginar que la presión del gas
real será menor a la presión del gas
ideal pero
vamos a pensar en que podríamos tener
una temperatura tan baja que incluso
alcanzaríamos el punto de condensación y
después las moléculas se moverán tan
despacio que empezarán a realmente
atraerse entre ellas o tendrán la
oportunidad de que se dé una interacción
de atracción que pueda digamos dominar
el movimiento cinético debido a la baja
temperatura así que podemos pensar en
que las moléculas se capturan y el gas
pasa a estado líquido y eso es lo que
pasa con las moléculas de vapor de agua
conforme disminuimos la temperatura nos
acercamos al punto de condensación o por
el contrario al punto de ebullición
dependiendo de la dirección pero ahora
veamos el otro caso pensemos en qué es
lo que pasa cuando tenemos una presión
alta y vamos a comparar lo que sucede en
un gas real y en un gas ideal en este
caso vamos a comparar el volumen de un
gas real con el volumen de
un gas y idea y vamos a mantener la
temperatura la presión y el número de
moles constantes entonces un gas ideal
voy a dibujar otra vez el contenedor
para un gas ideal no debe de importarnos
si se encuentra a una presión alta
porque suponemos que las moléculas se
golpean entre ellas muy frecuentemente
no sólo contra el contenedor sino
también entre ellas y dependiendo de qué
tan despreciable consideren el volumen
de un gas ideal podemos pensar en que
habrá más interacciones con el
contenedor pero si la presión es lo
suficientemente alta entonces ocurren
muchas colisiones y si realmente
queremos mantener la presión constante
especialmente si este volumen se vuelve
importante bueno si mantenemos la
presión constante al comparar un gas
ideal con un gas real tenemos que darle
más espacio al gas real porque el
volumen de las moléculas se vuelve
importante ahí empezamos a desafiar
su posición número 2 así que a la misma
presión en este caso a la misma presión
alta el volumen de un gas real es mayor
al volumen de un gas idea y bueno si
tenemos algo a una presión muy muy muy
alta esa es otra forma de llegar al
punto de condensación porque en general
si disminuimos la temperatura y
aumentamos la presión estamos cada vez
más cerca de que las moléculas
interactúen entre ellas y pasen al
estado líquido entonces aquí lo más
importante es que las suposiciones para
definir a un gas ideal y la ley de los
gases ideales son razonables para la
mayoría de los gases cuando tenemos una
temperatura relativamente alta y una
presión relativamente baja pero cuando
tenemos temperatura baja y presión alta
las cosas pueden fallar un poco